all right happy sunday everybody i know
it's odd to see us here on sunday
morning but we're happy to be here
for super bowl sunday it's clear uh
clear outside and it is cool we've got
temperatures in the 40s
but boy what a beautiful weekend we've
had so far
we hit the upper 60s yesterday gorgeous
sunshine
we're clear we've got winds up there at
kyle canyon and that's why
temperatures are just about matching
valley temps we've had gusts over 25
miles an hour through the night it's
gonna be a little breezy up there
if you want to head to the mountains we
still have high pressure but we've got a
lot of clouds out there in the pacific
and they're going to make their way
at times into our area as we get through
our week starting tomorrow
cold polar air is plunging into the
midwest the plains
wind chills at times down to zero and
even in the minus
teens and twenties as we get into today
and tomorrow
lots of snow and rain across the
mid-atlantic states and big
thunderstorms have been pounding florida
they just finished tornado watches that
have been in place overnight
and thunderstorms that hit tampa all of
those are
sliding to the south tampa should have
mostly sunny skies
for the afternoon through game time
should be okay thank goodness
69 for us super sunny for our super bowl
sunday then we start to see clouds
coming and going through the week
temperatures up near 70 degrees for most
days
through the eight day forecast until the
end of the week
we'll get cooler even 50s back by next
weekend